[Música]
Y este 15 de mayo se cumplió un mes del
más reciente conflicto en Sudán los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército y los
paramilitares de las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido Ya deja más de 600 muertos unos
700.000 desplazados internos y más de
100.000 personas que huyeron del país a
naciones vecinas para conversar sobre lo
que está en juego cuando se inicia ya un
segundo mes del conflicto saludamos en
Buenos Aires a Adán cauca él es
licenciado en relaciones internacionales
y ciencias políticas y además asesor
Internacional del instituto de estudios
estratégicos en seguridad señor cucauca
Bienvenido a directo a América
Muchas gracias por la invitación
quiero empezar preguntándole cómo ha
evolucionado el conflicto en Sudán a lo
largo del tiempo y cuáles son esas
principales etapas y eventos
significativos
bueno el judán Lamentablemente ha estado
en guerra civil y guerras regionales
desde hace décadas la más la más
dolorosa y profunda fue justamente la
que llevó a la secesión de Sudán del sur
este con Sudán que terminó en 2003 una
de Las Guerras más sangrientas de la
historia con más de dos millones de
muertos y 20 años entre las etnias
animistas y cristianas negras del Sur
del país de Sudán del sur y
las etnias más Árabes y musulmanas del
Norte y dio las etnias porque esto tiene
mucho que ver con todos estos conflictos
porque continuó luego del 2013 y la
sesión de Sudán de Sur continuó la
guerra civil en Sudán continuaron varias
regiones en guerra civil recordemos en
los ataques nada menos que a darfur que
tuvieron grandes repercusiones
internacionales y que llevaron a
criminal de justicia de la haya a
indicar a bachill para como criminal de
guerra por las masacres casi genocidios
en dalfurt con decenas de miles de
Muertos esto continuó y con por períodos
y justamente
en 2019 bajar
punto con eth meti dos grandes generales
que lucharon contra el gobierno de de
valleyr
derrocaron al gobierno de bachiller y
instalaron un sistema de transición
hacia la democracia lo cual no dejó de
ser solamente en los papeles había un
gobierno transicional que fue Derrotado
el año pasado básicamente por
el comandante jefe del ejército que
disolvió el gobierno civil es una
dictadura militar en cooperación
condetti
es difícil pronunciar estos nombres este
que también era uno de los líderes
militares más importantes en este caso
el representante de las temibles
chanyawick que fueron las las milicias
armadas que cometieron las masacres en
darfur esto es lo que ahora ese golpe
hace un año llegó a nuevos derrames
muchas muchos confrontamientos Cívico
militares y civiles muchas
manifestaciones y desde hace un mes para
hacerlo un poco más este sintético
estalló nuevamente la confrontación
del golpe militar entre hadetti y
hojametti y burham es el presidente
actual esto es como lo acabas de
escribir el último capítulo de una gran
confrontación Y si bien se puede
discutir a través de líneas étnicas
porque unos representan los los nómades
más berberes no
del desierto y otros más de otro tipo de
etnias más este de de Cartoon si bien
existe Todo eso y existe en ofensas
muy muy
atávicas este ya vamos a andar más más
adelante Qué pena lo interrumpo vamos a
andar más adelante en estos temas es que
no tenemos mucho tiempo precisamente
usted mencionaba estos dos líderes del
ejército y del grupo paramilitar solían
ser socios que cree que dañó su Alianza
al punto de llevarlos al combate bueno
Más allá de las
de las explícitas para afuera yo creo y
lo he analizado que hay intereses
económicos y
geopolíticos en juego muy fuerte que
tengan en cuenta que
es el que controla las minas de oro
es el principal fuente de recursos ahora
de Sudán y
burham Estaba tratando de tomar el
control de ese poder económico hay que
incluir acá los intereses rusos que
están asociados por ejemplo a través del
grupo Warner nada menos en la
explotación y el comercio de este oro y
tener en cuenta que burham quería
establecer y y el poder sobre este esta
economía en gran parte es informal hay
que tener en cuenta que exportó
Sudán 2600 millones de dólares el año
pasado pero se cree que mucho más fue en
forma informal a través de las milicias
justamente que se están ahora
confrontando
con lo cual vemos que hay intereses
económicos muy concretos muy cínicos
porque no son para el pueblo sudanés
sino son para los integrantes de la de
las élites de hecho gendeti es una de
las personas más ricas de África y por
supuesto la más rica de Sudán y hay
intereses geopolíticos muy fuertes como
la concepción de bases militares nada
menos que a Rusia la concepción de bases
militares a Turquía la concesión de
puertos en una zona que es el paso la
yugular del comercio internacional
porque es el acceso al Canal de suez
entre otras entre otras cuestiones
geopolíticas
está involucrado acá también la la toda
la ecuación muy conflictiva de toda
África que considerar que Etiopía con el
conflicto más sangriento el año pasado
que no fue Ucrania sino que fue el de la
también la guerra civil en Etiopía entre
el tigray y el gobierno central
limita con con Sudán y también todo
el conflicto de Centro África de Mali Y
por supuesto de Libia también que son
países en guerra civil actual se
sesionados todo está relacionado con
este conflicto y tiene su su influencia
por supuesto hay que tener en cuenta sí
[Música]
acordó con los con Estados Unidos y con
Israel señor Qué pena lo interrumpo es
que lamentablemente ya Se nos acabó el
tiempo teníamos aproximadamente unos 7
minutos para andar en varios temas Pero
bueno Ahí nos quedan pendientes más
adelante tal vez podremos abordarlos era
danko licenciado en relaciones
internacionales y ciencias políticas
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos en
directo a América
Muchas gracias por la invitación
bien Ustedes televidentes también
gracias por sintonizarnos no se
desconecten que en minutos regresamos
con más noticias en directo América
[Música]